benvenute anime fragili io sono con
l'elmo e sono qui per dare risposte e
ristoro a quelle domande che la notte vi
tormentano non vi fanno dormire amore
lavoro fortuna e quando si scopa sono
solamente alcuni degli spunti che
copriremo oggi grazie alle carte al mio
prezioso palantir non so come finire
questa frase ha dato risposta a tutti
quegli arcani quesiti
giusy il suo ragazzo riuscirà a trovare
la sua strada e stare bene finalmente
domanda al turista josie si vede che sei
una su tutte la situazione col tuo
ragazzo in questo momento criptica la
luna alunni erano in questo caso è solo
la luna stai lì a farti 2000 pare
pensando che la tua relazione col tuo
ragazzo dipende dalla sua felicità
dipende da te e soprattutto da voi qui
vedo il 4 di bastoni e non sto parlando
di un organo sto parlando di un accordo
un contratto che non ha funzionato
consiglio è quello di andare avanti
perché la soddisfa da al contrario avrà
presente l'intelletto di cui in questo
momento io credo una grande scarsezza e
al contrario e quindi giusy per il
prossimo mese ci serva crisi
dell'identità non si supererà tenete
assolutamente dovrò di più non posso
dire andiamo avanti il mio palla a terra
vedo un qualcosa che sembra che si sente
da un po di tempo con un ragazzo col
quale in sintonia che ha voglia di
conoscere biblicamente altre persone a
caso beh baldracco meotti ma vediamo un
pochino cosa dicono le carte è già
interessante la bellissima in un certo
senso fanno arrivare questi fumi vediamo
da un 2 di spade che verrà figura una
donna bloccata un pochino come sei tu in
questo momento su una persona bloccata
il cavaliere d'oro in questo momento
come potete vedere rappresenta una
sicurezza nella sicurezza che tu cerchi
su andiamo incontro al 5 di spade non la
vedo buona rappresenta liga
non su ingannevole cercherai di riempire
sia la botte che tornare ubriaca alla
sera non so però se questa cosa ti
porterà la felicità vedo un nome che
sembra una supercazzola impronunciabile
andare a lavorare in un posto a rischio
di attacchi terroristici mostra chiede
ti servono veramente le mie carte il mio
palantir per capire che è stata na
cazzata ma chiediamo finiamolo a queste
carte dell'udu cazzata alla casa
anche le carte dicono che è una
stronzata amici di al 6 di spade ti
dovresti allontanare dalle persone il 6
di bastoni ti farebbe sicuramente
sentire appieno ditte in qualche modo da
una persona che in qualche modo sta
facendo qualcosa di positivo ma andiamo
incontro a un carro al contrario
incidente frontale le carte dicono
pescia non nel senso di liquidi sakura a
te e alla tua bocca alle mi chiede se
arriverà dopo dieci anni di fidanzamento
questa proposta di matrimonio e
interessante mi piace farmi candy vostra
il matto quattro d'oro e un 10 d'oro al
contrario vedo poco cuore vedo molta
ricerca di stabilità di apparenze il
matto vuol dire che sei una matta il 4
d'oro rappresenta una stasi il 10 d'oro
è particolare perché è in questo momento
una dicotomia da una parte rappresenta
un mandare completamente tutto in vacca
dall'altra parte rappresenta una sorta
di stabilità che non ti darà gioia un
eventuale matrimonio potrebbe rivelarsi
un in bocca al lupo mandami l'invito
prendiamo il pala vediamo che cosa ci
dice qualcosa che ricorda la penna e
quel profumo di ken front sono spesso
vittima di ghosting dipende da meno
dagli altri
il problema il consiglio cosa succederà
si hai spesso a che fare con persone che
cercano deviate per il culo ma come dico
sempre in ghosting di per sé è una
risposta vuol dire cura persona a
nicotera un cazzo fanti meno pippe
mentali il 9 di spade queste ansie
spesso rischiano di allontanare le
persone e cerca di tornare un pochino
una spensieratezza in un certo senso ti
consiglia questo 6 di coppe la carta
dell'infanzia della memoria dei ricordi
perché così a tt male andiamo avanti mio
diletto
non posso dire il nome di questa persona
perché ha una relazione da un anno con
una persona sposata alla quale non
riesce a dire di no quella quale
vorrebbe chiudere come faccio mi viene
da pensare che quando la vulva chiama è
difficile non rispondere saccà l'arca
batum e il problema niente su cinque le
spade proprio quello che esce avete
tutti a che fa con teste di cazzo
consiglio
la soluzione beh
è che fare con un [ __ ] abbiamo anche
altre uscirà sto cinque le spalle
ballamy ballan tir palla micro la fame
cosa devo fare con la collega antipatica
che rende il mio lavoro è impossibile
infatti scarpe a punta e calci in culo
ma vediamo cosa dicono le carte vediamo
un pochino qual è la soluzione le carte
in questo momento ti suggeriscono di
digerire questa donna perché è
fondamentale mantenere i rapporti male
mi sentite qualcos'altro chiama una
onlus dal per palla mi vedo una quasi
sorella due anni di astinenza dal membro
chissà cosa avrà voluto dire sono un po
tantini dammi speranza è a volte il
membro è un po come l'asparago mie
stagionale qui vedo il problema
la soluzione
yuki abe per prime cose bisogna andare a
scavare nel passato perché cui vedo
l'ombra di un angelo oscuro ore di spa
di una persona brava parole a rigirare
le cose questo essere sicuramente ha in
qualche modo inficiato questa ricerca
dell'antico scettro del potere quello
che viene chiesto qui con il 6 di
bastoni ed efa un pochino più la
[ __ ] di concedersi il lusso di
andare in primis alla ricerca di un
membro che noi stiamo bloccando sul dove
andremo incontro a un'imperatrice al
contrario una scoperta naturale
interiore della tua femminilità un
qualcosa che abbiamo sepolto
la giovane lalla dice un ragazzo da un
anno che mi ama ma con lui il sasso
terribile perché dura più o meno un
minuto cosa se e jaco lazio per coach
l'antico note ma adoro quando escono
queste carte preparati a soletti perché
faccio bianchi come veniamo dal cibo di
pastori lotta immagino air nervoso che
tu possa provare nel fare un sesso
simile a un ordine da mcdonald's il
consiglio il 4 di spade come puoi vedere
una persona in questo momento può
sembrare una tomba ma in realtà è il
riposo di suggerisce di fare un attimo
un passo indietro smith infarti questo
scaricata aggiunge anche proprio è
scritto sotto usciranno fuori del
verità che siano le tue con le sue
abbastanza traumatiche di muller it e
anche abbastanza male a breve manderai a
cagare qualcuno che spiace se lo dicono
le carte lo devo dire vi do un mesetto
nepal marty qualcosa del genere che
piace un botto ma non è pronta una
relazione che fa in aspetti con lo manda
a cagare pendino fuori un ha mandato a
cagare via dal cazzo vediamo un pochino
che problemi salumi cosa potresti fare
dove si fa lui in realtà sa poi tedesco
va in giro e comunque in un momento nel
quale particolarmente tranquillo
emotivamente quindi non gliene frega un
cazzo chitarra a fare il decesso è
troppo sotto senza le carte guarda metto
a parte del secondo
come cazzo di piede che sta sotto a una
persona che ti dice che non ha voglia di
legarsi fish a molla affanculo mi sono
scordata le fattezze intime di un uomo
ne vedrò 1 presto giriamo di un al volo
che deve fare questa ragazza quanto i
bastoni a breve ti fidanzi cioè un
augello che viene con un anello e non è
per mantenere l'erezione pallante ma tu
stai scherzando
un elemento molto leggero che ricorda
anche uno dei protagonisti che chrome
vi scrivo spesso con l'amico del mio
ragazzo che faccio continua mi ci trovo
molto bene
esiste un incantesimo il migno tease
debilitanti che ti vorrei che in qualche
modo insegnare che cosa consigliano le
carte a questa demoniaca figura allora
allontanati molla il colpo sporco demone
perché per quanto questa persona di
interessi rischia di portarti nel
baratro della morte demone vattene via
da questa casa vattene via vattene via
mostro e molla per fare solo casini
scoprirà tutto probabilmente i tuoi
piedi taurini e caprini non puoi vederli
all'interno della stessa scarpa
quindicenne dono quando finisce la tante
mia no ragazzi non sono un virologo sono
semplicemente qui a monetizzare sulle
vostre sciagure sono tipo l'erede di
vanna marchi anni mi chiede quando
troverò uno alto 190 ben dotato con
occhi verdi ricco e stabile emotivamente
trovi chiamami perché io solitamente lo
trovo così prono eccoti come stai
ma secondo tempo una persona così non è
già stata accalappiata dall'appoggio
turbo [ __ ] presente sul pianeta le
persone così belle trovano altre persone
altrettanto belle noi non siamo
meritevoli detto ciò che lo voglio dare
il consiglio perché bisogna sempre
aprirci all'opportunità di farlo
ma in quanto il basso che al contrario
quindi dovrei animare da qualche parte
qualche cm tina di meno ea diener chi a
piccole anime fragili sicuramente la
fine di questo video fatemi sapere qua
sotto quali sono dei quesiti e quali
vorreste che io risponde insieme alle
carte e al palantir perché la prossima
volta
io ci sono non prenderò convinti dall
instagram omari prendono direttamente
dai commenti di youtube e la prossima
volta ci sarà solamente se arriveremo a
almeno 40.000 light note vi invito a
iscrivervi a questo canale altrimenti
peste ricordo che arrivando un enorme
bacio spirituale del servo col mio terzo
occhio e una grattatina dei [ __ ] ci
vediamo presto
chi lo sa